if we take 30 000 down today okay thirty
thousand thirty thousand down today and
we do times thirty five is what that
means that will be at a million in 42
years so meaning long term you're gonna
be fine long term Innovation is going to
be fine but for people that are sitting
there saying I truly want to create
wealth you have to if you have some
savings right now you did it right
you're going to be able to capitalize
because a lot of things are going to be
on sale you're going to buy a condo a
house on nothing in my opinion in the
next 12 months the level of discounted
properties is going to be insane in 12
months like discount in a way that you
never thought you'd be paying that kind
of a discount on 12 months you have to
also be thinking about this is if you're
if you're 30 years old this is probably
going to happen only five times in your
lifetime if you're 40 years old it's
probably only going to happen four times
in your lifetime if you're 20 years old
six times wow you have to be ready for
your the next one that's gonna happen in
10 years and the way you do that is by
piling up a bunch of cash and you make
some good Investments and 10 years from
now you ready when it happens again